j'observe une forme de résignation en
tout cas de la société vis-à-vis de
marine le pen elle peut aller n'importe
où n'importe quel plateau de télévision
raconter n'importe quoi sans que
personne ne la reprenne je vais donner
deux exemples récents sans nommer ceux
qui sont concernés mais enfin tout le
monde comprendra elle va dans une
émission avec lui qui a 7 millions de
chômeurs en france
moi je suis plutôt appuyé sur les
sciences sociales ou que je regarde ça
de presse je ne sais pas d'où sortent
ces statistiques elle est complètement
fantaisistes et mensongères elle dit que
non pas du tout il ya rien aucun
problème au parlement européen
tous les emplois fictifs qu'on lui
reproche c'est un mauvais procès de
l'europe contre l or qui a pas un qui a
bossé pour le front national qui s'est
occupé de quelques dossiers européens
que ce soit donc il ya bien de l'argent
de l'europe qui a été détourné pour
faire fonctionner un parti politique
français mais personne ne lui dit rien
et je trouve que dans cette espèce de
capacités qu'elle a à dire n'importe
quoi sans que personne ne lui rappelle
un certain nombre de principes il ya un
indicateur de résignation disons disons
de les journées de la société voilà et
delà de ces journalistes de la société
en général et ça c'est pas possible
moi je sais aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles je m'engage dans cette
campagne et je soutiens benoît hamon je
pense qu'il faut mener le combat deux
fronts à la fois vis-à-vis de manuels de
marine le pen mais aussi et surtout sur
l'affirmation d'un certain nombre de
vérités de réalité dans la vie publique
on peut pas dire n'importe quoi car
quand on dit n'importe quoi ça donne
donald trump
hier ça peut donner marine le pen de
demain ici et elle peut gagner demain
oui vous faites partie de ceux qui
considèrent qu'elle peut gagner et
notamment si on renoncer si elle renonce
c'est sûr mais celui-ci par avance on
renonce ont commencé dans la politique
celui qui l'y attend
certains sondeurs disent que sa
meilleure chance de l'emporter au second
tour ce serait d'affronter benoît hamon
vraiment faim moi le sondeur voilà qui
sonde
moi je m'occupe pas les sondeurs sa
chaussure qui sont je les lis jeu mais
je les prends avec la distance qu'il
qu'il faut c'est pas une science je
crois qu'on l'a vu ces derniers mois
en revanche qu'il ya danger le pen oui
et ce danger il est d'autant plus grand
danger ses bras avant même de livrer que
danger d'avoir arrivée à l'elysée
choix